sin respiro para Nicolás sajossí este 17
de mayo el expresidente francés vio
rechazado su recurso contra una condena
de tres años por corrupción y tráfico de
influencias San José fue condenado en
marzo de 2021 junto con su abogado tía y
el ex magistrado principal Gilbert
siendo la primera vez que un
expresidente francés Es declarado
culpable en un caso de corrupción San
José y axof fueron acusados de solicitar
información procesal sobre un caso
relacionado con el expresidente ante el
tribunal supremo de Francia a cambio de
prometer ayuda a Gilbert a obtener un
cargo honorífico en Mónaco los dos
habían sido puestos bajo vigilancia
telefónica como parte de una
investigación sobre la supuesta
financiación en la campaña presidencial
de saxo en 2007 por parte del ex líder
libio muamarga daffy sasko sí estaba
usando una segunda línea telefónica
clandestina bajo el nombre ficticio de
Paul bismut el expresidente siempre ha
protestado por su inocencia es aceptable
que me espíen en mis conversaciones más
íntimas y que me mantengan bajo custodia
durante 15 horas están tratando de
humillarme a pesar de su condena zasko
sí ha logrado evitar la prisión su
sentencia original de tres años ha sido
confirmada pero se le permitió cumplir
un año de custodia en casa con un
brazalete electrónico
de 67 años también ha sido inhabilitado
Para ocupar un cargo o cualquier función
pública durante tres años